あー
目かいー
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
はい、花粉症の人　手あげて
いや、手あげなくていい
高評価押してくれ！
花粉症の人高評価押してくれ
花粉症じゃない人、高評ｋ
ばばん！（大塩平八郎）
てわけでみなさん花粉どうお過ごしでしょうか
僕もねいろいろ試しますよ
マスクしたり
.............
鼻かんだり
とかしかしてないですけども
まぁいろんなね花粉症の対策の仕方があるわけですよ
まぁ人によっちゃ薬を飲んだりね
鼻うがいしたりね
ガスマスク付けたり
外に出ない
杉の木を焼く
伐採
レーザー治療
とかもあるんですけど
こう鼻にね、レーザーでジュッって焼いて
花粉が入らないようにする
いろんな対策の方法があると思うんですけども
今日は.......花粉を買いました笑
笑
花粉を買いました
冷凍で届いたんですけど
なんで冷凍かは知んないけど冷凍で届いたんすよ
これたぶん世界初じゃないかな
花粉の開封動画
うわぁー.....すげぇな
ガチだ
見えますでしょうか、花粉送付書でございます
えーと今回買ったのはスギ花粉でございます
20グラムのスギ花粉です
大丈夫かな俺.....俺大丈夫だよね
アレルギーでなんかぽっくり逝ったりしないよね
大丈夫だよこうゆうなんかね
荒治療もあるって俺知ってるから
はい、　うわぁこれだぁ笑
スギ花粉　でございます
君たちは花粉をシャットアウトしようとしてるだろ
俺は花粉と仲良くなりたいんだよ
俺はフレンドリーにいきたいと思ってる花粉とは
これからの人生長い付き合いになるからさ
もしお前この先に
花粉に何か助けられなければいけなくなったとき
花粉が助けてくれなかったらどうする
そのときに花粉がいなくなったらどうする
そうゆうこともあるから
俺は君たちみたいに隔離する道を選ばずに
おれは花粉との共存をエロぶ
俺は花粉との共存を選ぶよ
今ここで20グラムの花粉を被ると
ひょっとしたらもう花粉浴びすぎて
花粉に強くなれるかもしれない
そーゆー原理なんすよ
えー怖いなー
花粉テロだよー
え、もうなんか鼻むずむずしてきた
え、まずい！やばい！
え、あ、うーわ、へぇっくしょん
くそー
あぁぅわ
へぇっくしょん
やばい！
ちょっと待って、まだ、何もしてないんだけど
ちょっと大丈夫かなぁ
もう、いろいろやばいんだけど
まぁこれでおれがうまくいったら君たちもやってくれ
これで俺がひょっとしてなんか
なんかアレルギーでやばいことになったら
マネはやめてくれ
俺が開拓するよ
花粉治療法を
はい中身はこういたって粉です
花粉て食えんのかなぁ
ちょっと食ってみますわ
あ、味はしないです
ちょっとざらざらしてる
カレーのスパイスみたいな感じ
特に問題はないっす
ぶっっっ
これをどうやって処方するかですよ
直接目にかけるのは痛いですよねたぶん
なんで
ふーってやってぶぁー！ってする
そしたら俺の部屋がやばいよ
どうしよう
20グラムって意外と多いな
絶対これはちょっと部屋でやるべきではないと思う
ちょっとダメージを最小限に食い止めるために
風呂場でやります
まじで部屋ではやんないほうがいいと思った
たぶん俺の今後の人生に支障が出る
そして俺んちに人が来たらその人も死ぬ
本題はねこれをどうするかなんですよ
あー、なんともいえないかんじだな
ふっ
あ、目、目にはいった
今目に入った
へぇっくしょん
へぇっくしょん あああ
食ってもいいけどさぁ
別に食ったら意味ない気がする
へぇっくしょん　へぇっくしょん
考えたんですけど
一番手っ取り早いんは
粉を出して
それをふってやって
ぶぅわ！ってやって体にまとう
それが多分ね、一番手っ取り早いと思います
ここになるべく出して
残りは頭からかぶって
あ、あ、あ、やばい、これ詰んだんじゃね
ちょっとまって、、、
え
でこれをふってやるとたぶん俺は花粉まみれになる
えやべ俺受粉、受粉してる
これふってやったら
へぇっくしょん
（くしゃみ連発）
あ、心臓がもたない
いい！治りそうだ
もっとくらおうはじめ
もうちょいいこう
もうちょっと食らえば治りそうな気がする
ああ
へぇっくしょん
（くしゃみ連発）
みんな、まねしちゃだめだよ！（がらがら声）
これがちの声だからね（がらがら声）
俺ふざけてないからね（がらがら声）
本気の声だから！
絶対、マネしないように
じゃあな